Visit all of the pages of the web,
we actually render each page
in a real web browser
so that our AI can see the page
just like a human does.
It can see the actual pixels,
the look of the page.
So, it's more than
just a text of a page.
Mike Tung, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you
all the way from Silicon Valley?
I'm doing well.
Thanks a lot for having me.
I'm very excited
to chat with you about AI,
about your entrepreneurial journey,
what you're doing at Diffbot.
But we have to go back
to being a child musician
playing at Carnegie Hall.
What is that about?
How do you get
to play Carnegie Hall as a child?
Well, I think my story is similar
to a lot of Chinese Americans,
they're sort of forced
to play an instrument
at a young age by their family.
But I think,
you know, the main purpose of that
is just to learn discipline
and learn practice.
So, as a child,
I played the violin for maybe,
I don't know,
about 18 years or so before college.
And I ended up playing
with a group at Carnegie Hall.
That's remarkable.
So, you grew up in Taiwan, right?
You're an immigrant from Taiwan.
Tell me a little bit
about your background
and moving along with that background
through Carnegie Hall
to get to doing AI
at Stanford for your Masters.
Wow. It's a lot to compress in it.
A lot of years to compress.
But basically, I was born in Taiwan.
I immigrated to the US
when I was about two years old.
So, I don't remember too much
about Taiwan from back then.
But my parents, my dad
came to the US as a grad student,
studying biochemistry,
and he later on taught at universities
as a professor in pathology.
And later off to spun
and founded his own biotech company.
That he's developing actually vaccines
for HIV and even one for covid
right now, over in Atlanta, Georgia.
Wow.
And so, I grew up
in a very entrepreneurial family.
Growing up in a
very entrepreneurial family,
what does that mean?
You immigrated from Taiwan.
You were telling me about
what your father was doing,
but what does it mean
being in an entrepreneurial family?
Well, it just means I guess
it was something accepted
or at least not crazy
to be an entrepreneur
since it ran in the family, I guess.
However, you know,
while the rest of my family
is sort of in at biotech in biology
and I worked at my dad's lab
actually growing up,
and I realized that, you know,
it's I wasn't cut out
sort of to do biology.
I spent many hours waiting
for centrifuges to run, you know,
extracting DNA and building viruses
and watching various kinds
of clear fluids develop.
And, you know,
I needed a faster iteration cycle
than that waiting days and days
for an experiment to run
and not knowing where you messed up,
maybe like in day two.
And that's kind of how
I came to computer science.
So, you're looking
from this agile approach
where you get to see results fast,
iterate, pivot, iterate
and get to deeper results.
And you find your way
towards Stanford master's in AI,
working in the AI lab.
Talk to me a little bit about
what you're doing there.
And what draws you specifically
to artificial intelligence then?
Well, I mean, so it just started out
playing with computers,
developing video games,
I think like a lot of the typical story
of a lot of computer programmers.
And after high school, actually,
I instead of going directly to college,
I worked for about a year
at Microsoft as a software engineer.
Because I thought growing up,
Microsoft is the place where they
really invented software development.
Right.
And I read about Bill Gates story.
And then so I went there.
I got to meet him.
Like all the interns are invited
to his house over the summer.
I think back then,
I got to go to his backyard
and check out his place.
And I learned a ton
when I was at Microsoft.
But I also realized,
I probably don't want
to work in a big company
for the rest of my life.
What made you realize that?
What was it about
the big company,
that culture that you said,
okay, maybe, I'm more into
the small company space?
Well, I thought
it was a great experience
actually working at Microsoft.
I learned
an incredible deal about
how like professional software
development is done,
but I realized,
I want to do something of my own.
I want to I, you know,
my bosses and mentors
when I was working at Microsoft,
I had to really think,
do I really want to be like that
in 20 years or 30 years.
Right?
Kind of doing that kind of work.
And I just wanted to do more.
And I wanted to work in a place
that I was not constrained
by the organization
where I was sort of like,
I think that's why a lot of people
do entrepreneurship,
because they can't really work
for anybody else.
So, throughout these experiences,
you are getting into the,
more into the artificial intelligence,
what do you actually do at Stanford?
What is your masters in
and what leads you then towards
this idea for Diffbot?
Yeah. So, I was interested in AI,
I guess, way before it was popular
from a pretty young age.
Like when I was
even in high school,
I was like developing
neural networks to like
the trade stocks and stuff
from reading like a sentiment
on the very nascent Internet
at that point in time.
So, I had always
been fascinated by AI
and building intelligent systems.
At Berkeley, I finished
an undergrad in ECS
in about two years
and then quickly
moved to grad school at Stanford.
And I took a heavy concentration
in AI courses.
And so, it was at around
that time when
there was a data set
that was being built
at Stanford called ImageNet,
which was basically like,
you know, a large collection
of labeled images.
They basically use
Amazon Mechanical Turk
to label all these images
from Google image search.
And I was thinking, okay,
how can we build
like an image net for language.
Because, unlike vision, like
the human language,
what we're using right now
is what distinguishes
humans from animals.
Like even my dog has computer vision.
He can tell the difference between
this ball and a toy,
you know, a grassy field.
But animals don't have anything
like human language.
Right?
So, I was thinking about this problem
and why is there no, like,
image net for language,
even today,
there isn't really something like that.
And it's because
there's way more concepts
that humans have created
than there are like
a thousand image classes.
And it would take
up to 50 man decades
in order to
build such a data set.
Right?
So, that's when I started thinking.
Okay, what if we could use AI
to automatically construct
actually a structured data set
of all the concepts
that  human beings care about.
What greater resources there
than the Internet itself.
The Internet I view as basically
kind of like the world's largest
manmade censor.
Anything that's an important entity,
someone's created a page
for on the Internet.
Right?
And the only problem
with the Internet is that
it's not an structured format
that's needed for machine learning
and AI to use.
So, I started thinking
back then about how
can we actually convert the Internet
into actually like a structured data set
that then applications can use.
Wow. Fascinating.
So, that's the research
that you're going towards.
And I'm also aware
that you've given
quite a few guest lectures at Stanford
about Knowledge Graphs
and about the different
work that you've done in this field.
So, take me through this
entrepreneurial journey.
How do you take
a research question
that you're so excited about
and translate that into a company
that you're running along
with the work that you're doing
at Stanford?
Well, I wouldn't say
it was a very direct journey.
So, I don't think you
just start on such a task
like that directly.
During Stanford,
I was doing this research
and, you know, sort of,
I guess, trying to delay
from writing a thesis
because it's very hard to come up
with, like a breakthrough
machine learning algorithm.
And so I was doing a lot
of side things.
Like I was actually working
as a patent attorney.
I'd taken the patent bar
and helping a friend
in a right path
to make money on the side
as a side hustle.
I actually I ended up
working for a startup
that one of my professors at Stanford,
Dr. Professor Prabhakar Raghavan,
who's now
a very important person at Google.
He said I was taking
his information retrieval class
and then he pulled me aside after
basically the end of the class and said,
"Hey, I'm doing the startup
that I'm an adviser of.
Would you join us? "
So, I joined it as one of the
sort of the founding engineers.
Of course, that's what happens at Stanford.
Yeah.
It's a very common story at Stanford.
That startup,
years later, gets acquired by Facebook.
I also had
sort of did a project with somebody
called ClickTV,
that was like a video search engine
that then we later sold to Cisco.
Right.
So, I had a couple of acquisitions
under my belt.
And I had worked as
a consulting scientist at Yahoo!
on their search,
and on eBay on their search.
So, the trend here is I got a lot
of experience in building
a search engine like from scratch.
And these connections
sort of paid off later.
Like eBay, became
one of the first customers of Diffbot.
There's actually
a group on eBay in Israel called
the Structured Data Group
that uses Diffbot.
I'm good friends with that group.
I worked with eBay closely
on some projects that I did
in my transition between
high school and the army.
And it's a really fantastic team.
Yeah. They were a user of Diffbot
and then some of those engineers there
basically, Diffbot replaced their work
and then later we hired them
to join Diffbot from
one of the guys from eBay Isreal.
Fantastic. Fantastic.
So, what is Diffbot?
And I'd love to spend some time
hearing another
amazing Founders' story.
So, taking things through your
like, you know,
the personal journey that you're like,
you know, from deciding to run a company,
what are some of the biggest hurdles
that you're going through along?
What are some of the most
enjoyable moments
of creating this company?
Okay, so the first question,
what is Diffbot?
So, basically, Diffbot is
a search engine.
Now, how it differs from Google,
how it's the same as Google
is that we crawl the web, right?
So we visit all
the pages of the Web.
We actually render each page
in a real Web browser
so that our AI can see
the page just like a human does,
it can see the actual pixels,
the look of the page.
So, more than just a text of the page.
And then what we do is
how the AI comes into play is,
on every page on the Web
we're able to classify that page
into what type of page is it.
Is it as a person page,
is it an organization page,
is it a product page,
is it an image page.
And we're able
to automatically convert
this into structured information.
Right?
So, like a structured record
about a person, place or thing.
And then what we build is
what we call the knowledge graph,
which is essentially
a structured database.
Right?
So how it differs when you
use Google, for example,
what Google is,
as type in a query
and then Google gives
you back a sorted list of results.
Right.
So, Google is similar
to a card catalog in a library
where it's directing you
to other pages to read.
Right?
And then Google's business model
is to auction off
basically your attention
to the highest bidder
and advertisers.
There's a trade off, I guess,
between relevance and advertising.
Right?
And then Google doesn't
actually contain the knowledge.
It's actually just routing you
to Web pages, which you read,
and then you gain knowledge
reading those results.
Diffbot is actually doing
the reading of those Web pages,
you know, using our AI,
assembling it into this
structured data set,
and then returning back
those facts directly
from our index.
And so the reason Diffbot is useful,
especially for people building
applications and businesses,
is if you're building an app,
let's say you cannot just
directly access a search engine.
You need structure data
to show in your app,
to use it in your app.
Right?
So, for example,
like Snapchat is one
of the customers of Diffbot.
We power like the stories feature
those articles,
news stories inside Snapchat.
We also power other search engines
like DuckDuckGo.
When you see like
those news titles
or organization titles.
If you are like a business
that has like a CRM,
we can actually
take every record in your CRM
and automatically enrich and enhance it
using the information we have,
the knowledge graph.
So think of it almost like,
you know, like a professional
search engine that
a business application can use.
Right?
All of your other business tools
that you use are not generally
like ad supported software.
That's like consumer software.
Like your Microsoft Word
or Zoom doesn't have like
pop up button inside it.
That's how it's like supported.
How do you get
to the realization that
this is even something that's needed?
So, you know, if I were to,
even as I am studying
artificial intelligence at Stanford
and I'm working on a lot
of these questions,
I would never imagine,
like maybe I should build
a competitive search engine
that could create structured
data out of the World Wide Web.
Well, so, you study AI so,
you know, there's basically
like three drivers,
right of improving AI performance.
There's the hardware,
the software and then the data.
Right?
So, I realized early on
that the hardware,
I can never really compete there.
I'm not going
to compete against Intel
or TSMC or Samsung
and come up with better hardware.
Right?
Nvidia. There's already billions
of dollars invested in that area.
Right.
The software, well,
I was trying to compete in that
in grad school,
developing new algorithms.
Right?
But then there's
like Google tensor flow.
There is Pytorch, there's all this,
the software is always getting better.
And there's so many people
coming up with better algorithms
all the time as well.
Right?
But when you start to think about data
and you want to build
an intelligence system,
you need structure data.
Well, what does everyone do?
They end up
just collecting their own data.
They end up just
kind of rolling their own
for their own application
using the data they have.
There isn't really like
a kind of a knowledge store
where you could just kind of say,
I want to import this data
from the source.
And I have a core set of people,
organizations or articles
or information to start out with
that I can tap into.
And so that's an area where I
saw there is actually a gap.
And looking at things like image net,
you can see that
it was actually this data set
that resulted in this new
revolution and deep learning.
It wasn't actually any novel,
new algorithm that was invented.
Because neural networks
have been around
since at least the 60s and 70s.
So, it's when I realized,
hey, why can't we build
like an everything store of data
and structure the world's knowledge
and build like
a new kind of search engine
for these intelligent
applications can use.
Right. So, share with me,
let's say a use case
that I'm building application
that has something to do with sports.
Right?
Let's say that I'm
that I'm dealing a lot with
the FIFA soccer tournament
or with the NFL
and I want to make use
of this knowledge database
that you're accumulating
by taking the World Wide Web
and tape making it
into structured data,
how would that used case look like
from your perspective,
if I were to want to
use Diffbot for example?
Yeah. So, I can show you an example.
Amazing.
So, with sports,
one of our customers is called
Sports Innovation Lab.
And what they do is basically
they produce business intelligence
for owners of sports teams
and sports executives.
So, they're using
the Diffbot knowledge graph
in order to track like
what's developing all these
events in the sports world.
Sure.
The players, the teams,
they're using it to track like,
which teams have covid,
which teams are shutting down,
how are things like re-openings.
So, it's helping sports executives
really navigate sort of the re-opening
like post covid.
And so, they're using
the knowledge graph
to keep track of all these things.
Right? Because,
it seems like things are changing
in the news on a daily basis
with each team
and each player.
It's too much for like
a human to keep track of.
Our AI is actually we crawl the web
keeping track of all that,
presenting the API dashboard for them.
We're going to put a box
right above your head
of how it's going to look.
So, how does a company like
that interact with Diffbot
on their day to day
both on the application level,
but also on the consumer level?
Yeah. I shared with you
a link to basically
how it looks like to the end user.
But you can see basically
there's this dashboard
that shows a visualization
across time of various sporting
world related events, you know,
as it relates to covid and sports.
And so you can see
it's sort of curated
by the team on each team.
It shows like, you know,
when that seat,
that league was postponed,
when it reopens,
like athlete data,
like whether a player has covid.
Wow.
That's very, very cool.
What was the most surprising part
of the start of journey for you until now?
I mean, startup Journey has so many
surprises in it, I guess.
With Diffbot, I'm surprised
by different use cases of
our technology out all the time.
Right?
Every day you hear about
one of our customers
using it in a way
that you didn't expect
the technology to be used in.
So, I think that's
one cool thing about building like
a platforms kind of company,
is that the
people are free to use it in lots
of different ways that you
wouldn't have imagined.
And so it creates more innovation.
100%.
It also requires some
open mindedness and some creativity.
And you're going to accept it
and to roll along
with that understanding
that you're seeing these
radically new use cases
that you didn't expect,
but you're embracing them
and now you're able
to understand the magnitude
of what you're building
Mike, this was really wonderful.
And I love what you're doing.
I know that you're also hiring.
So, I'm guessing that
if anybody here
is into this kind of stuff
and would like to reach out,
I can make the intro.
That's okay with you?
Yeah, definitely.
We're probably the best place
in the world if you care
about building automatic
knowledge graphs using AI
right from the whole web.
Besides Google and Bing,
we are the only
other US entity that crawls
the entire Internet.
So, we have our own facility here
in the Bay Area
that crawls the web and has a copy of it.
Unbelievable.
How many people
are in the company right now?
We're a little less than
40 people right now.
Wow.
That's very, very impressive.
It's mind boggling to me.
A team of less than 40 people
making sense of the entire Internet,
crawling the entire Internet.
That's just you know,
it was unbelievable
when Larry and Sergey attempted
to do it in 1998,
when the Internet was this small.
It's even more impressive
when you're trying to do
when the Internet is this big.
Mike, before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
This is a tough question
to reduce, like a human
just to like three bits.
But I would say
if I were to only choose three words
in my entry into
Diffbot knowledge graph,
it would probably be
machine learning engineer.
Because that probably
most describes what I do,
like engineering machine
learning systems,
and that describes the core of
what I do as a CEO.
I love that.
Mike, thank you very, very much.
And this was really great.
I learned a lot.
Thank you for being so generous
with your time
and best of luck.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Great. Thanks for having me, Michael.